I'm Tyler Volk professor of biology and
environmental studies at New York
University author of several books death
and sex guy his body toward a physiology
of Earth meta patterns across space-time
in mind
yeah well
have long lives because they're made of
fundamental particles that themselves
are long-lived to infinity there's some
issues about the proton having some kind
of long decay constant but organisms are
dynamical systems made of parts enzymes
that interact very volatile II they have
to be rebuilt constantly they organisms
in cells have to have constant inputs of
matter and energy in order to carry on
to regenerate these these these complex
internal dynamics that they have going
all the time
the body the body wears down after a
while the there are repair mechanisms
that we have you cut your skin you
notice that your skin repairs you break
a bone the bone repairs
many of these repair mechanisms as is
any of us who are aging know become less
efficient as we get older and one reason
that diseases become more more
statistically probable as we get older
has to do with a general running out of
the of these repair mechanisms the
efficiency of these repair mechanism
mechanisms that were with us buy from
our birth as human beings but have
themselves a kind of a longevity that
varies from individual to individual but
you can see most people when they're
when they get around be around 70 or 80
90 you know they're going to look old
there's certain expectations so there's
some commonality that we have as humans
as a species in terms of shared genetic
capabilities of repairing our bodies
that wears down over time
we have a lot of trouble embracing death
because we know it's going to happen and
this really flies in the face of our
urge to live which we're coming out of
billions of years of organisms being
successful at living and passing on
progeny and suddenly in the last thirty
thousand years a hundred thousand years
we don't really know the euro some of
the earliest detailed elaborate burials
were thirty thousand years ago you know
human beings not only died but they they
know they're going to die of course many
of the world's religions have not liked
this fact and so try to build up various
kinds of mythologies about afterlife
but I think the basic reason it's just
it's abhorrent to us it's you know we've
built up the self we we we've had for
the most part enjoyable experiences
there's more to experience we have loved
ones we we have roles in life and
suddenly to know that that's just going
to all be ending snuffed out at some
point is you know really puts in a kind
of a primal dilemma to our to our minds
yeah I think some of these urges to like
conquer death or to live for a long time
you know have to do with this this this
primal fear of death itself of course we
want to stay healthy
it's painful to get ill it's painful to
get old to have injuries that don't heal
so well to have permanent pains so some
of that is overcoming just a sense of
unwell being that happens to us we want
we want medicine to make progress and
and keep us healthy but the other factor
is is wanting to live for a long time
and maybe you know maybe forever it's
not clear what we would do or how that
would affect our our lies and some times
science fiction writers explore those
kinds of themes but I see that it's
incredibly natural and I do think it's
going to not that we're going to live
forever necessarily I don't have a an
informed opinion about that but from my
reading of typically a nature magazine
science magazine and some of the
biological findings and also what I see
happening with the genetics and genomics
research in my own biology department of
NYU it's clear that advances are going
to be coming to help us fulfill some of
these dreams we've had since the Upper
Paleolithic of living for a long time
I don't believe in any afterlife for
myself I don't think my mind continues
after I die and that doesn't feel
particularly good so my recourse is to
go by Who I am what we have see myself
as a product of billions of years of
evolution and during which time this
evolutionary process has discovered and
utilized in various ways forms of death
in in support of life it doesn't make it
it doesn't make it something that I look
forward to I definitely do not but I can
see myself part of a larger picture and
I think there's a lot of gratitude I've
developed as a result of understanding
of how death and life are intertwined
and doing some of my investigations that
I've written about in how death and life
are closely coupled with each other in
the support of life that we know
without death there's no evolution as
least as far as we know it
one could hypothesize some organism that
may live forever that would you know bud
off mutations but it would evolution as
it works now operates by organisms dying
and the next generations carry on and
those generations for the most part have
very variance in them and then those
variants are selected and so you can get
a you can get a sort of design happening
out of evolution over time or you can
get adaptations occurring that did not
exist so for example at one point there
were no large creatures such as us or
elephants or dinosaurs or amphibians
walking around on land there were
vertebrates called fish in the world's
oceans and then they were able to emerge
and go up on land the only way that
could happen would be many generations
dying many generations of fish with
certain kinds of limbs dying and there
were slow variations accumulating to
turn those fish into tetrapods
four-legged creatures that would either
be in the mud in the shallow water and
eventually crawl up out of the ocean so
so death has really been essential an
essential ingredient to the evolutionary
process
cells are dying in our bodies all the
time the race that they die in are
replaced varies depending on what organ
we're looking at so for example the the
skin the cells and the skin are turned
over approximately every month of time
your skin is migrating new cells are
migrating outward and the old cells are
slough off and that makes some sense the
skin is the subject to a lot of wear and
tear and abrasion it's it's in contact
with the with a harsh environment and so
for the skin to have some kind of way to
renew itself is very essential by having
a border around our body's organs such
as the brain and the heart the cells
there many of those cells either aren't
intended to die they don't really have
turnover in some parts of the brain it's
being discovered the cells do have
turnover but clearly the places such as
the brain and the heart in which the
interconnectivity of the cells and the
cells working together is really crucial
in those organs that turnover is a lot
less so the body through the
evolutionary process has tuned death in
a kind of adaptive manner to to ensure
that these organs are are healthy
depending on what what function these
organs have to play there's also a role
of death in development that all large
creatures we know have the really good
example is is our hand with our five
fingers the fingers do not grow as stems
of a tree might grow in which they start
small and they just they just grow
outward you might think that that
happens that they're starting their
course they're small when they're in in
the womb but instead the hand starts off
more like a paddle kind of like a thick
very thick ping-pong paddle and the
fingers in this embryonic stage are
formed by the cells in between dying off
so the fingers of the first extension of
the fingers are formed by by a
developmental form of death it's a
program death if this is death being
controlled
not just the turnover that I described
later earlier of the of the skin turning
over but these cells die in between and
they don't they don't die and then fall
away that they die in or their
reabsorbed into the hand and so it's a
form of recycling but the the formation
of the hand and this is true of the
human hand the mouse hand there's many
examples of this and if if there is not
controlled what's called program cell
death very precisely sculpting the the
the developing organism it's been shown
that these organisms can die that death
is absolutely essential in the early
developmental process
one thing I write about is the fact that
there's not just one death there's
there's different forms of death there's
there's the death of our bodies that has
to do with the senescence of us being a
large multicellular creature a metazoan
having to do with the slowing down of
the repair mechanisms but there's also a
lot of death inside our bodies as we
live the death of our cells skin cells
are always sloughing off in internal
cells are dying cells that go aberrant
go through a kind of suicide program so
there's a lot of death inside our bodies
all the time going on that is essential
to our life and this is somewhat of a
different death from that from the death
of our bodies as as large organisms and
then there's also death on smaller
scales in bacteria that either have to
do with they're running out of nutrients
that's that that is an inadvertent form
of death but there's also kinds of
bacteria which are multicellular and
they can have programmed cell death in
there as when they go into the
reproductive phases so one issue about
death that I find particularly
fascinating is that there is not just
one kind of death but death has been
really incorporated into life in various
forms depending on what scale of nature
were looking at
our our closest primate relatives are
the chimpanzees and gorillas with the
chimpanzees being closer in to us
genetically their natural lifespans are
approximately half of ours and that's
that's of some interest because the
chimpanzees are a bit smaller than us in
body mass and the gorillas are larger
than us in body mass we can't know for
sure the the the lifespan of the last
common ancestor of humans and
chimpanzees but there would be some you
might guess that it would be half of of
what our current lifespan is
yeah let's make it to stay
that we're not talking about the
infant's diet a small children dying of
childhood diseases or death of a
predator but but the the natural
lifespan in in normal perf almost
perfect circumstances so it looks at
throughout history we've we've there's
always been people that have made it to
age 80 or so or longer even though the
average life expectancy at Birth given
all factors given diseases predators and
then the the diseases of Aging and
senescence even though those have been
more prevalent the the natural lifespan
has been approximately the same as it is
today the maximum the natural maximum
lifespan which is different from life
expectancy at birth which can vary even
in different countries today right
Russia right now has a relatively low
life expectancy people in Africa have a
relatively low life expectancy Japan has
the highest life expectancy of any
nation now so there's variations but
take those individuals into relatively
equal healthy environments and they're
all going to live close to the same age
right the the natural life expectancy
has not gone up very much however since
the diseases some of the diseases that
modern medicine is tackling such as
heart disease and cancer become more and
more the diseases that we are dying from
in elderly age we we can be expected to
live longer without trying to
genetically go in and you know and
manipulate our metabolisms in some ways
there's a lot of research being done on
what is called caloric restriction
animals that are given reduced calorie
diets and yet have the nutrient the
essential nutrients that they need live
longer we haven't been able to do the
experiments on human beings yet there
are people out there attempting this by
themselves you can get books and join
organizations to to try to enhance or
help you what knows what how you can
make recipes that that satisfy your
hunger and have caloric restriction and
this is I'm saying this to show that
there probably are going to be ways that
science is going to understand this
natural demise this metabolic demise of
our repair mechanisms that set our
natural lifespan have kept it pretty
constant for a long period of time and
we're probably going to bring that
forward we're gonna live longer lives I
really think I don't know if it's right
around the corner but that's that's hard
to judge you've had people on your show
that are saying what they think it's
going to be but but just from reading
the literature it's clear to me that
these kinds of advances are going to
happen
I find it really fascinating to consider
why certain species of mammals live
longer than other species of mammals for
example we live longer than dogs dogs
live longer than mice often there's a
tendency or a trend in in that the large
creatures live longer but you might try
to say from an evolutionary viewpoint
that it would serve creatures well to
live for a long time they can reap they
can reproduce more let's say if they
live for longer and therefore pass on
their genes for even a longer period of
time but we know that there's a large
variation in wind creatures senesce and
what the average lifespan is and it
turns out there's two ways of looking at
this one is to go down deep into the
organisms and say and ask why are the
cellular repair mechanisms breaking down
when they do a couple years in the case
of some small mammals for us it's it's
it's many decades 70 80 90 years but the
other way to look at it is that these
cellular repair mechanisms themselves
must be subject to evolution now they
can we know that these repair mechanisms
vary among creatures it's been shown
that birds for example have better
cellular repair mechanisms than mammals
do the the current reasoning has to do
with the the ecological niche that a
certain creature lives within as a
member of its species and if that niche
allows a sort of allows the possibility
for many of the individuals to live long
lives then it has been worthwhile for
the evolutionary process to build in
longer better repair mechanisms for its
cells to in to allow it to live longer
so if I go back to the example of birds
the phrase that's sometimes used in the
technical literature for birds and why
the birds live so much longer than
mammals of the same body mass is is the
phrase fly now die later
and the idea being that birds in the
trees and in flying are have a have very
good predator escape mechanisms that
make it worthwhile for the birds to have
cellular repair mechanisms inside their
bodies that allow this longevity for a
certain body mass to occur and what I
find fascinating here is that there is a
tuning of the creatures niche or
environmental lifestyle and the
possibilities that that lifestyle has
for longevity and the very internal deep
internal cellular repair mechanisms even
the enzyme repair mechanisms issues
about octave the oxidative stress that
either facilitate that longevity or or
cut the life short one particular
example I think is very very telling is
the case of the several species of
Pacific salmon that live in the
northwest in the United States and up in
Canada and in Alaska these salmon are
born in upstream freshwater streams or
rivers very quickly they they go down to
the saltwater ocean so they have a
transition from freshwater to saltwater
ocean they live in the ocean for
typically two to three years depending
on the species they find their way back
through process somewhat mysterious but
maybe having to do with the water
chemistry of their birth stream they
find their way back to their birth
stream and at that point the the males
and the females undergo some
physiological changes their bodies turn
more red they bulk out the males the
jaws get very very bolt out and if you
look at their what's happening hormonal
E in them it's like they're on an
incredible dose of steroids they're
they're revved up for this upstream swim
that we see dramatic pictures of you
know where they're swimming these Rapids
and can they hop this Dam or not or do
they have ladders to go up they go
upstream
the males and females mate they the the
females lay the eggs and these little
depressions in the sediments and then
the males and females all die they do
not go back downstream to let's say live
another year and come back upstream and
you might think that would be that
what's happening is a real waste of
these salmon it's been shown that they
add some nutrients to the upstream water
but they're not dying to add nutrients
to the to the upstream waters they're
dying because the what's happened to
their bodies has put such stress on
their bodies that they they've they've
done this incredible swim and put all
their efforts into into getting to a
place to mate and into mating and this
is a wonderful example of how it's
important for these organisms to remain
healthy up until sex up until successful
sex and reproduction and then it's
possible to die senescence is is
possible just after sex you know if
there was senescence before sex that
creature is out of the evolutionary game
obviously but you could have death
fouling right on the heels of sex and in
the case of the salmon this has occurred
in in in the evolutions and so so we can
see here that there is a tuning between
death and when senescence happens and
the the ecological or environmental
circumstances that have resulted in
various adaptations for for that for the
case in the case of the Pacific salmon a
really dramatic case
you walk in the woods and the whole
forest floor is filled with the litter
from the trees the dead material from
the trees that's fallen down to the
forest floor and is feeding the the
creatures in the soil there's a lot of
life in the soil many species of
bacteria we don't yet know a lot of
worms other creepy crawly things in the
soil they're basically living on the
detritus the the dead material is coming
from above either in the form of dead
parts of plants entire plants dead
animals
waste products from animals mushrooms
rise and then and then die fall back to
the forest floor and so the whole
ecosystem is working by the efficient
recycling of the dead we can put a
number on that through in the following
way we can we can put a number on how
the recycling of the dead actually
enhances life we can see it happening in
the forest floor but I'll just walk you
through the number the total amount of
carbon that photosynthesizing plants and
algae require on an annual basis is
about 100 billion tons of carbon that
they incorporate either pulling it in
from the ocean water in the case of
algae or pulling it in from the air to
go into the leaves of plants in the case
of trees and other plants on land about
100 billion tons of carbon a year we can
ask what if plants had to rely on what
if the plants that algae had to rely on
new carbon that was coming up from deep
going into the atmosphere and ocean from
volcanoes from the dissolution of rocks
that contain carbon and that amount is
about 1/2 of a billion tons per year so
were the photosynthesizers
to rely on this carbon coming up from
deep that's fresh going into the ocean
atmosphere that's only a half one half
of a billion tons per year
the current abundance the beautiful
abundance of green life on the planet is
requiring about one
hundred billion tons of carbon per year
so that's a two hundred to one ratio and
they get there they get this one hundred
ninety nine parts over over the the half
billion tonnes it comes up fresh from
from below from the recycling of
organisms from our breasts from the from
the breaths of the elephants the Eagles
from the breaths of the snakes from from
the breath of the the bacteria or the
the the the gases being put out as waste
products mote from bacteria that's
really the bulk of this recycling from
the bacteria in the ocean and the and
the and the soil and so one can say that
from the efficient recycling of the dead
and the fact that the creatures that are
putting forth co2 such as ourselves are
are living on the dead because we are
going to either you know eat animals or
eat plant eat animal to eat the plants
so there's death to support our bodies
that this that these this webbing of
nature in which dead becomes life and
life becomes dead around and around
enhances life we can say approximately
200 times there's approximately 200
times more life on the planet with with
this networking of life and death that
happens
humans are part of this but we are
relatively small in terms of our bodies
decomposing and going into the cycle the
big the big carbon fluxes are really in
the realm of all plants the back the
bacteria in the soil we are we are
creating more if we are creating more
and more carbon fluxes what we are
putting more and more of the Earth's
carbon fluxes in these earth cycles
under our own control with taking over
10% of the planet using 10% of the
planet for for agriculture and another
maybe 10 to 20% for for grazing of
various kinds and the fisheries so with
our population we are we are we're
bringing more of this death and life
cycle under control the actual
contributions of our bodies dying is is
of course relatively small compared to
the all these larger pictures